what should Democrats be doing
in order to win in the south?
BILL: Mayor Mitch Landrieu,
-Oh, good question.
-MITCH: Tell the truth.
BILL: Tell the truth?
Tell the truth. It's important.
You know, when--
You don't have to go to
the far left,
you don't have to go to
the far right.
Mayors, we solve problems.
And I think people kinda look
at Congress and say,
"How come you can't solve
any problems?"
and that's what we do.
And people are not
as ideologically bent,
I believe, in the country,
as we seem to think
that they are.
And I just think you gotta
get things done, figure it out--
If we only had a country
run by all women mayors.
-That's true. I'm for that.
-(APPLAUSE)
-Then we'd have everything...
-I'm for that,
But we're gonna have a fight
in the Democratic party,
like the Republicans are gonna
have, about center, left, right.
It's gonna be a battle royale,
and it will prepare us for
the future.
Alright. Chris Hayes,
what do you say to people
that claim that MSNBC
is the liberal equivalent
to Fox News?
I have defended your network
many times on that point,
it makes me crazy.
And that-- Well, because,
you know, Fox News does not
stick to reality.
MSNBC is liberal-leaning,
but they stick to reality.
But I'll let you
answer that question.
What do you say to people?
And that your network
only focuses on Trump
for profits?
Um... So, I'll take
the first question,
which is that the way
to understand Fox News
is it was built by a very unique
man named Roger Ailes...
-BILL: Yeah.
-...who had a foot
in two different worlds.
He was a TV, show business guy,
and he was a politics guy.
This is a guy who advised
Richard Nixon,
he advised George H. W. Bush.
What he was building,
and the owner of that network,
Robert-- Rupert Murdoch,
was explicitly a political
project.
That was the goal from
the beginning.
It was an ideological project,
it was a political project,
it was a media project.
That has never been the case
at MSNBC.
It's never been the case.
There is no Roger Ailes
at MSNBC.
It was never... Believe me.
It was not built by any
Ailes-like figure.
It ended up being where it is
in prime-time largely because
-it found an audience for that.
-BILL: Right, it wasn't
originally...
-It was a reflection-- Yes.
-Lou Dobbs was on it, remember?
Yeah, and it was
a reflection of the fact
that, by hook and by crook,
a market demand was found,
which brings us to the second
point, that you focus on Trump
for ratings.
Donald Trump's the President
of the United States,
and it turns out,
people really wanna...
hear about what the President
of the United States is doing.
-And there's only so much...
-Yes.
...that you're gonna apologize
for covering the President
of the United States.
BILL: Right. And I'll...
-(APPLAUSE)
-Yes, and...
Everybody's ratings are up
due to Donald Trump,
and by the way, he loves that,
and takes credit for it.
-CHRIS: Right.
It's his favorite thing.
-I mean, he was just--
-Did you see him in Pennsyl--?
-Except he doesn't want anyone
else to make money on the fact
that they're using his image
and persona to make money.
He wants to figure out how it
can all come to him.
Did you see him in Pennsylvania
before the special election,
-when he did the robot?
-Yeah.
And he was saying,
"You'd hate it if I was boring!"
-(MONA SIGHS) You know--
-As if the most important thing
is that the emperor
-toss bread and circuses out...
-MONA: Which...
-BILL: ...to the hoi polloi.
-Absolutely. And in fact,
-that's how he picks people.
Apparently, he liked Bolton...
-CHRIS: Yeah.
-BILL: Yes.
-...because he's interesting,
as opposed to McMaster,
who was boring.
-BILL: Boring!
-Yeah.
(LAUGHS)
BILL: Alright, Mona, in 2003,
you called liberals
"useful idiots of the Russians."
Would you say it applies
to Republicans and Trump now?
-(LAUGHS) Okay, so,
first of all--
-BILL: Did you quote--?
So, the title of my book was
"Useful Idiots." It was...
-BILL: It's in the title!
-...a term of art, okay?
It was the quote from
Vladimir Lenin, who said that
liberals in the West would be
useful idiots for us,
and we could tell them all kinds
of lies and they'd repeat them,
and you know, so that was what
my point was.
I think it's still valid.
And I think, yes,
it does apply to some
Republicans today.
-BILL: And Trump, especially.
-And Trump. Regarding Trump,
yeah it does.
-Totally a useful idiot.
-MONA: Not all, though!
There's some--
You know what? I just want
to say this on behalf
of the Republican party,
since I've been hard
on them tonight.
I do think that we can
either save
this great American institution,
or we can turn the page.
And I think we should save
the Republican party.
Well-- Or maybe,
I keep saying, go back
to Republican Classic.
-You know. I think
they should run--
-MONA: Yeah. Yeah, right.
Not the New Coke.
BILL: No, not the new one.
They need a Mitt Romney.
Somebody who's... You know,
Mitt Romney's looking
-pretty good now.
-MONA: Yeah.
(LAUGHTER)
Uh... Gina, are there any
EPA regulations
that you would be in favor
of repealing?
That's a really good question.
Yeah, the ones about those
garage door openers...
(LAUGHTER)
CHRIS: She's running!
She's running!
-MITCH: She's running!
She is, Gina!
-CHRIS: She's running!
-(APPLAUSE)
-She's running.
-I'd like to make
an announcement.
-CHRIS: Yeah!
(LAUGHTER)
Well, I don't love every
regulation.
-You only regulate when you feel
like there's a need to do that.
-BILL: Right.
When somebody is harming
somebody else,
-and you need to resolve
a market failure.
-Yes.
So, yeah, there are some that
should go away,
and we look at them, we are
required to look at them,
like, every five or eight years.
You look at them,
you make changes.
You try to keep up to date.
But what you don't do
is go in with a list
of things you want to get rid of
-regardless of knowing anything
about them or looking at them...
-CHRIS: Yeah.
...and do it for the sole
purpose of reducing
business cost
to certain constituencies.
-That's not what you do.
-(APPLAUSE)
-Okay.
-CHRIS: True.
-Wicked-good answer.
-Thank you.
-MITCH: "Wicked..." (LAUGHS)
-It was wicked!
How... (LAUGHS)
How will Trump's
trade war de-stabilize
US foreign relations?
You know, he kinda went back on
the steel one, right?
-And then he put ones
on Chinese...
-CHRIS: Well, it's a great--
It's just like a mean girl
with a shit-list.
There's no rhyme or--
The steel tariffs is
a great example
of very efficient means
of producing corruption.
-BILL: Right. (LAUGHS)
-Which is to say, "I announce
a blanket tariff,
-but I'll make some one-on-one
side deals with everybody."
-MONA: True.
Like, "Maybe you stay
at the Trump Hotel,
and maybe you hook up
my son-in-law
with some financing,
and maybe we can work out--"
-It really is a classic means
of using the state...
-BILL: Yeah.
...to produce corruption.
And now, we've got all these
individual bi-lateral deals.
They're gonna carve it out.
Ultimately, what it's going
to end up with is,
China's gonna sort of
punch us back.
Right now, we are not in
a trade war.
We're at the beginnings of
something that might become it.
Right now, it's fairly
penny ante...
but if it gets worse,
it's gonna have real,
real consequences.
I can't wait for the Trump
voter to walk into Walmart,
and there's nothing there.
(LAUGHTER)
Alright. Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, panel.